[Musica]
Buonasera Bellano Ciao a tutti e a tutte
io sono Matteo Viano e sono un
pallavolista o meglio
lo sono diventato perché
nasciamo esseri umani ed è solo che
essendo vivendo E diventeremo
io se li penso ai miei inizi nel mondo
sportivo no a quando ero teenager per
intenderci mi ricordo che
c'è un percorso da seguire per diventare
uno sportivo no c'era tutta una serie di
cose che mi avrebbero portato verso
questo traguardo No era come se ci fosse
una ricetta perfetta
da raggiungere
questo incasellarmi e incanalarmi mi
metteva forse un po' un po' d'ansia e
soprattutto non rientravo in quella che
era la ricetta perfetta
che sentivo o che mi consigliavano gli
altri e quando ha 18 anni sono andato
via di casa per provare a diventare
un pallavolista
non rientravo minimamente nelle cose che
mi proponevano e non avevo poi se ben
chiara Qual era la mia ricetta
dell'equilibrio però sapevo che c'era
e quindi questa sera
io mi giro sempre dalla parte sbagliata
Questa sera
vi chiedo gentilmente di giocare con me
e vi invito tutti a chiudere gli occhi
lo state facendo No chiudete gli occhi
Grazie e dopo che avete chiuso gli occhi
vi invito a con una mano
a portarla davanti al vostro viso e con
l'indice o con l'anulare perché noi la
Bellano Siamo gente creativa vi invito a
disegnare quella che per voi è la forma
dell'equilibrio al mio trema Che devo
cercare di guardarvi 1 2 e 3
Ragazzi ma siete pazzeschi qui ne ho
viste un decimo perché dopo molto
contento allora vi ringrazio perché
avete giocato con me credo che giocare
sia la parola che dobbiamo portarci
dietro del nostro essere stati dei
bambini perché è importante Dobbiamo
conservare veramente tanto e ne ho viste
di diverse per fortuna ho visto quella
che che cercavo che è questa
perché io a 18 anni sì vabbè ciao Io 18
anni
avevo questa idea che era una linea
dritta immobile e statica no E quando
ero liceale io giocavo al lavoro
allenavo dei ragazzini facevo teatro in
lingua italiana teatro in lingua
francese facevo il corso dopo pronto
soccorritore e ho consulta studentesca E
facevo anche a me il tamburino al Palio
di Asti e tutte queste cose messe
insieme su questa linea statica
cozzavano
e non è sbagliato voler fare tante cose
o essere tante tante persone
bisogna trovare la forma adatta e quindi
quello che voglio fare con voi è provare
a immaginare questa forma che avete
creato
o anche la forma del vostro equilibrio
come se fosse fatta di una corda in modo
che possa prendere delle delle curve
possa adattarsi e possa cambiare nel
corso della nostra vita
una parola importante che ho inserito in
questo piano è scelte
io
sono
appunto in Seria da tanti anni ho
giocato tanto in nazionale e adesso mi
sto per laureare in scienze motorie e ho
32 anni perché sono di ottobre e ho
fatto un corso in questo percorso di
studi che si chiamava teoria e
metodologia del Movimento umano che
praticamente spiega come e quanto il
movimento sia importantissimo per il
nostro sviluppo non solo motorio ma
proprio psichico e fisico persone il mio
professore qua non c'è e anche il mio
relatore della tesi credo degna perché
sicuramente non è stata la migliore
spiegazione ma per farvi capire
quanto anche il mio percorso di studi mi
se sei servito nella nell'essere atleta
e in questo corso Ho imparato che ci
sono delle capacità coordinative che
alleniamo tantissimo quando siamo
bambini e che continueremo ad allenare
tutta la vita tra queste c'è proprio la
capacità di equilibrio io in quella
linea statica sicuramente non sognavo di
laurearmi a 32 anni credo e nel 2016 o
2017 ho deciso di congelare gli studi e
quando l'ho fatto ero dispiaciuto perché
pensavo di deludere papà che ci teneva
tantissimo al mio percorso universitario
e sentivo di aver fallito
Il bello è che dentro di me Non pensavo
di aver fallito Sinceramente però è un
sentimento che tenevo più per la noiosa
opinione altrui quella che sinceramente
credo contraddistingue un po' la nostra
società a riguardo dell'università
e che avevo altri interessi non avevo
energia umane in quel poco tempo libero
che mi lasciava la pallavolo per
dedicarmi all'università e uno di questi
grandi progetti che ha unito dei valori
come lo sforzano l'amicizia lo stare
insieme l'etica la solidarietà è stato
proprio brodo di vecchi che ho creato
con un mio grandissimo amico che è Luca
Vittori e che è iniziato come una web
radio e podcast in un momento in cui
pochissime persone lo facevano Cioè è
vero e quindi
è nato proprio da un'esigenza da
un'esigenza perché noi avevamo sportivi
e giustamente la nostra caratteristica
forse era l'immagine anche proprio nel
gesto tecnico della pallavolo noi
volevamo un po' cercare di uscire da
questa immagine abbiamo scelto la voce
la voce per poter essere alto e abbiamo
cercato di dire dei mondi perché la
nazionale e la maglia azzurra che
vuole esperienza sportiva più bella che
ho fatto e mi fa sempre venire il
sorriso quando ne parlo e ti dà una
responsabilità e un'opportunità sportiva
gigante
una responsabilità perché comunque se
uno dei 12 14 atleti che rappresentano
l'Italia e quindi i giochi delle
competizioni
importantissime È un'opportunità perché
appunto non lo possono fare tutti allo
stesso tempo però è una responsabilità È
un'opportunità umana Secondo me perché
riesce ad arrivare a molte persone a
molti giovani e puoi portare te stesso
puoi portare quello in cui credi i tuoi
valori e insieme alle esigenze Noi
abbiamo Unito la responsabilità sociale
perché gli zii di Luca sono dei
missionari laici severani e lo hanno
fatto per tantissimi anni in Congo dove
nella città di gomma nel quartiere
indosso c'è questo laboratorio
sartoriale dove iniziano a imparare
questo mestiere tantissimi ragazzi e
ragazze che finiscono un percorso
di studi diciamo molto difficile lontano
da dal nostro e abbiamo cercato di
sostenere questo progetto creando una
linea sartoriale una linea di di oggetti
e poi lo abbiamo unito all'Italia
andando a cercare dai tantissimi giovani
che sognano magari di fare quello per
cui hanno studiato quello che la loro
passione che siano salti stilisti
creativi e così abbiamo unito l'Africa
in Italia in questo in questo
progetto molto bello e un altro progetto
che leggo alla responsabilità sociale è
stato il Revolution Volley Camp gli
avevo dato sto nome un po' così un po'
focoso però E vabbè che era il mio Kent
io ho voluto fortemente fare perché non
volevo andare a fare la guest star o col
campione nei Camp Ah perché non mi si
sentono Evviva che volevo
riportare quello che ero stato io da
ragazzino quindi magari non fortissimo
però mi piaceva così tanto la pallavolo
e quindi ho detto io voglio mettermi
sullo stesso livello che muove questi
ragazzi che è la passione perché eravamo
tutti la stessa passione la cosa che ci
differenziava e a livello in cui
giocavamo e quindi l'ho fatto insieme a
tanti miei amici e colleghi sportivi
questo Camp ed è orientato proprio su
questo sullo stare insieme è ovvio sullo
sport e sull'impegno che ci vuole
cercando di fargli capire come in una
settimana tu devi creare una squadra con
persone che non conosci con persone che
sono diversi da te che magari non sono
neanche al tuo stesso livello ma devi
cercare di cooperare con queste persone
adattandoti cercare di rispettare le
altre unicità e non è per forza di cose
che dobbiamo essere amici di tutti o
devono piacerci tutti dobbiamo
rispettare le altre persone e cercare di
fare squadra e infatti
l'adattamento è un'altra parola che
ho messo in questo piano perché
Secondo me senza adattamento la capacità
di equilibrio tentenna un po' e
l'equilibrio lo possiamo perdere per
cause esterne come per esempio una
spinta o quello che a scuola guida
chiamano il suolo struzzolevole o anche
per delle cause interne ovvero quando ci
quando ci muoviamo Noi muovendoci
perdiamo e riprendiamo molto velocemente
l'equilibrio
e il movimento Ci serve per muoverci
liberamente
e
muovendoci nell'arco della nostra vita
in più di meno incontriamo dei momenti
difficili alcuni ne incontrano tanti
qualcuno per sua fortuna un po' meno
alcuni di questi momenti sono
lunghissimi e
secondo me Io ho pensato che in questi
momenti possiamo fare come faremo con il
nostro corpo ovvero allarghiamo la base
di appoggio e abbassiamo il baricentro
in questa posizione il mio equilibrio è
molto più solido e quindi riesco a
essere residente e resistente alle
intemperie
e il sapersi dosare e sapere mantenere
l'equilibrio ci serve per una cosa di
cui tutti abbiamo il diritto
che brillare e noi dobbiamo avere il
diritto e possiamo brillare nel nostro
piccolo
o per il mondo e quindi una volta che
riprendiamo le forze le energie ci
solleviamo in piedi dritti alti piedi e
siamo pronti per per brillare
Io questi momenti difficili li ho
catalogati con questa parola che
cicatrici e ho scelto cicatrici per chi
ne ho tante perché mi sono operato molte
volte e quindi le ho veramente sul mio
corpo
queste cicatrici sono un po' come dei
nodi che si formano su quella corda con
cui abbiamo
creato il nostro piano di equilibrio
e non le vorremmo è ovvio però sono
queste che ci rendono quello che siamo
adesso sono le cicatrici sono i nodi
che ci permettono di ricreare un nuovo
piano di equilibrio che si è vero Ci
sentiamo persi Forse quando si crolla
Quello su cui ci appoggiavamo avevamo
pensato tutto
però è anche quello che ci rende forti
il fatto di crearne di nuovi e saperci
adattare Io ora sogno di essere un piano
a cui le persone possano appoggiarsi e
un piano da qui le persone possono anche
slanciarsi perché la parola per me più
importante e inserito
in questo questa ricetta mia
dell'equilibrio sono proprio le persone
perché i legami che noi creiamo con le
persone sono quelli che ci fanno
crescere e
quando io penso alle persone penso
proprio a allo slancio no che c'è
nell'andare incontro a qualcuno e in
questo slancio c'è una perdita di
equilibrio Ma perché vogliamo
raggiungere a qualcuno e lo stesso la
stessa perdita di equilibrio sei
nell'accogliere qualcuno
io nessun 10 parole in questo piano
perché vabbè è un po' il mio numero ma
perché non abbiamo abbastanza dita per
contarle è proprio per il discorso che
non è non è un numero Secondo me così
perfetto
ed è amore
L'amore è una di quelle cose che forse
ci fa perdere di più l'equilibrio No
perché noi pensiamo all'amore tante
volte come una cosa nostra come una cosa
concreta un qualcosa che Boh Possiamo
dosare siamo più preoccupati a pensarlo
che a darlo o a riceverlo e quando siamo
non so innamorati o in preda all'amore
non si preoccupiamo più se siamo non
siamo in equilibrio ci stiamo e basta e
l'amore è tantissime cose L'amore è
l'amore di una mamma l'amore di un papà
l'amore di due mamme l'amore di due papà
l'amore verso gli amici l'amore verso un
animale verso un luogo verso qualcuno
che ci insegna qualcosa l'amore adesso
un partner verso qualcuno o qualcuna che
stimiamo Senza conoscerlo
L'amore ha tantissime forme e pensarle
tutte ci fa perdere l'equilibrio
viverle è parte fondamentale di questo
piano di equilibrio
io ho scritto un libro qualche anno fa
e il giorno del mio ventinovesimo
compleanno che è un giorno prima di
rientrare in sala operatoria per
l'ennesima volta e l'ho scritto con la
mia psicologa dello sport è un libro che
sicuramente parla di sport nel mio
percorso e parla tanto di vulnerabilità
perché
è andando incontro e capendo la mia
vulnerabilità che ho capito di essere
forte Io sono forte Sì con le mie
fragilità e questo mi ha fatto capire
anche di essere libero e consapevole
tante volte mi sono sentito
a disagio mi sento e mi sentirò a
disagio
schivato o in imbarazzo per alcune
situazioni in cui magari mi ritrovo no
all'interno della nostra società credo
che ogni tanto siamo inseriti in dei
rettangoli veramente molto spigolosi che
ti possono anche anche ferire e ho
cercato qualche volta di rendere questi
rettangoli un po' più simili a dei
Cerchi no anche a delle forme un po' più
astratte come quelle che se avete
disegnato
a volte ci si riesce a volte no quando
non ci riesco cerco di immaginarmi
magari che possono essere un po' più
tondeggianti Questo per dire che non ci
sono delle forme perfette per
l'equilibrio di ognuno di noi bambini
rettangoli vanno bene i cerchi vanno
bene qualsiasi forma abbiate nella
vostra testa le uniche forme che
dobbiamo veramente allontanare
sono quelle che contengono l'odio e la
discriminazione
io
penso che abbiamo un dovere importante
che quello che dobbiamo dire ai prossimi
e alle prossime che non sono nel futuro
sono le persone che abbiamo vicino noi
il fallimento non esiste Esistono le
parti diverse gli inciampi gli errori le
scelte sbagliate gli obiettivi non
raggiunti sono tutte cicatrici sono
tutti nodi della nostra corda e
scioglieremo o che scioglieranno
io
vi auguro veramente la migliore forma
che che possiate avere e che anche Sei
diversa da quella delle persone che sono
vicino a voi ma vi fa stare bene È bello
che sia così l'importante è che non sia
discapito di altri o del mondo Noi siamo
esseri umani non siamo perfetti non lo
saremo mai Noi siamo uno stupendo
meraviglioso gioco di equilibrio e
quindi vi auguro questa forma che faccia
bene a voi e che magari riesca anche a
fare bene A questo mondo Grazie
[Musica]